the original space jam was one of my
favorite childhood movies so when i
heard there was gonna be a space jam too
i was like
stop it get some help in this video
we'll be going over some of the biggest
differences between the original space
jam 1996 and space jam a new legacy
and there's a ton of controversy
revolving around some of these
differences from
lola bunny's new look to the removal of
pepe le pew we'll get into that plus
dozens of other cool easter eggs and
hopefully by the end of this video we'll
see which
space jam is superior i want to know
what your favorite is in the comments
below but before we begin make sure to
slam dunk that like and subscribe button
seriously only three percent of you are
subscribed and stick around for the
answer to a bonus trivia question can
you name the only
actor to be a part of both the original
and new legacy
the answer to this at the end other than
new legacy being a half hour longer than
the original both versions start with a
flashback of our main characters
playing basketball as kids in fact new
legacy shoots the flashback scenes in
film
rather than digital to make it feel
closer to the original the kid versions
of our protagonist
are shown with their parents in new
legacy it's the mother and space jam the
father but it's new legacy that really
takes off and makes family an
integral part of the plot even
incorporating lebron's son dom
heavily into the story in space jam
michael jordan shows up and mentions his
family once it's pretty hilarious
i should also mention that the actors
portraying lebron's family are not his
real family in fact the names of his
wife and kids have been changed the
events of space jam take place around
1996 which is two years before young
lebron james plays the bugs bunny game
boy game as a child
that being said the main events of new
legacy take place in present day and the
plot takes advantage of this by
structuring both the villain
and the story around a futuristic server
owned by warner brothers did warner
brothers really just make a movie where
warner brothers is the villain
great i'm gonna get copyright strike the
introduction credits are markedly
similar for these two films both showing
career highlights of our protagonists
fun fact lebron and michael both wear
the number 23. we're quickly introduced
to new legacy's villain
algae rhythm portrayed by don cheadle
he's juxtaposed
with swank hammer yes that's his name
voiced by danny devito
each villain has their own motivation
swing camera wants the looney tunes as
slaves for his amusement park on [ __ ]
mountain to help counter sagging
attendants
algorithm wants recognition believing if
he combines lebron's fame with his
tech he'll no longer go unnoticed in new
legacy algorithm actually ends up
playing in the game unlike hammer in the
original we never visit the warner
brothers lot but it's front and center
in new
legacy where they use every chance that
they can get to put in posters of other
warner brothers properties like
joker and aquaman in fact that's what
i've seen as one of the biggest
criticisms of new legacy
the background warner brothers
characters like white walkers the mass
the penguin distract from the story
in the original the crowd is composed of
all looney tune characters and only
three human characters make it to tune
world michael jordan
bill murray and the goofy sidekick
character stan played by wayne knight
there's no such character like that in
new legacy
the crowd in new legacy is almost
entirely replaced by human characters
as lebron is pitch algorithm's idea of
him being scanned into different movies
we do get a slight nod to the original
space jam with the poster here in fact
there
are very few flat out references to the
events of the original probably the most
obvious one happens during the lola
bunny wonder woman segment where bugs
bunny tries to recruit her
how often do you get to play with it nba
superstar
this essentially confirms the two movies
are directly related plus we do get very
brief shots of the small
alien creatures who composed the goon
squad in space jam however their team
name in that movie was the monstarz
lebron and michael also have two very
different takes on basketball for lebron
basketball is life and he can't afford
to take time away from the game it's not
me
and i can't afford to take time away
from the game in space jam michael is
the opposite he's quit
basketball in order to pursue a baseball
career one of the main differences
between these characters is how they get
transported to toon world in space jam
it's through a golf course hole as
michael jordan is lassoed by yosemite
sam in new legacy it's the villain who
transports lebron into the server where
not only looney tunes world is located
but all of the warner brothers
sweet sweet intellectual property to
name a few game of thrones harry potter
and wizard of oz
one thing i do like about new legacy
over space jam is that they put the
stakes of the story on lebron
much sooner than in space jam about 20
minutes into the movie lebron is told by
al that if he doesn't win his game he'll
be stuck in the server verse away from
his family forever
in space jam it's the toons who will
become slaves and not
michael michael helps the tunes get out
of this predicament whereas in new
legacy the
tunes help lebron what i'm trying to say
is
we need your help listen
i need your help it isn't until
four-fifths through the movie a new deal
is struck that puts michael's fate
on the line unlike space jam when lebron
makes it to toon world he finds out it's
only inhabited by one person
bugs bunny the others have left after
being enticed by algorithm into getting
digitized so
bug and lebron have to scour the
universe searching for their teammates
this never happens in space jam nor do
the scenes in which lebron is placed in
famous warner brothers movies
another key difference is that when
michael first lands in toon world he's
in his human form in new legacy lebron
is in traditional 2d animation
in space jam we only see michael in
animated form for a brief moment when
swankhammer warns what will happen to
him if he loses but for the most part
he's
all live action lebron will later turn
into his normal self when algorithm
upgrades him in the tunes resulting in
the tunes given a 3d facelift
both versions have their fair share of
product placement like lebron sneakers
here but space jam
definitely has new legacy beat get your
hands on lace up your nikes grab your
wheaties and your gatorade we'll pick up
a big mac on the way to the ballpark
while lebron navigates downtown toon
world we'll see an acme van
acme is a lot more present in new legacy
than it is in space champ there's even a
reference to michigan j
frog with the singing frog theater we
actually get to see him in space jam
as lebron teams up with bugs bunny he'll
get turned into a basketball similar to
michael there are some callbacks to
famous looney tunes cartoons here like
the rabbit of sebille
or long-haired hair where bugs plays a
conductor these old cartoons aren't
quite referenced in space jam
lebron and bugs are able to commandeer
marvin the martian spacecraft in order
to round up the team
however that's pretty much the extent of
marvin's role in the film
in space jam he actually acts as a
referee and we never get to see his dog
canine well i guess we should get to the
political part of the video where we
talk about why certain changes or
exclusions were made
of course i'm talking about the absence
of pepe le pew and the visual changes to
lola bunny
originally in the casablanca sequence
pepe le pew was supposed to hit on jane
the virgin actress gracie sento kissing
her arm in getting a drink poured on him
because of his unwarranted advances
lebron then walks over to him where he
learns pepe's love interest penelope
pussycat
has a restraining order against him and
lebron says pepe just can't go around
grabbing other tunes without their
consent
so the director and warner brothers just
decided to cut that whole thing
it's kind of weird that they got rid of
pepe yet kept characters like the
murderous pennywise and the droogs from
a clockwork orange you don't want to
know what they did to women in that
movie
unlike pepe who was cut entirely lola
bunny was redesigned in fact they
include an
entire sequence where she competes in
the wonder woman obstacle course which
seeks to showcase her strength over her
sexuality the constant hitting on by
bugs bunny torter and space jam has also
been toned down
in the original he literally gets hard
like a piece of wood
in both versions bugs sacrifices himself
so that lola doesn't get hurt but in
space gem he's rewarded for his
sacrifice with a kiss oh yeah you also
don't have foghorn lagorn spanking
george p
dog in the background a big addition to
new legacy is gossamer in the most
recent looney tunes cartoons he's a
character who hunts down bugs bunny
we never see him in the original on the
other side of things al needs a team to
battle lebron and the tunes and
unlike space jam where swan camera's
minions steal the talent of some of the
nba's best players al has these players
copied and brought into the server verse
as
monster manifestations the game
announcers have also been changed in
space jam the announcers are hubi and
birdie from the cartoons while a new
legacy they're performed by actual
sportscaster ernie johnson jr
and the guy who kicked ass from get out
granny is also in both films her real
name is
emma webster and in space jam she's more
of a cheerleader than a player
unlike the original lebron's family
actually gets sucked into the game where
they watch the events unfold
it sets up a lot more emotional moments
which the original lacks however i
personally felt these emotional moments
fell flat partly because the background
was so distracting all the bg characters
made me easily lose focus of what was
happening right in front of me did
anyone else feel this way
we do get to see yakko wakko and dot
from animaniacs which was my personal
favorite addition
the courts themselves are different in
each movie the practice courted space
jam is a typical gym while a new legacy
it's in space the real court where the
game takes place is an arena in space
jam while in new legacy it's the
futuristic court that even has a force
field because a new legacy the game is
based off dom's video game
players can achieve style points and
bonuses that's why when the game ends
the score is 1042-1041 compared to 7877
in the original now i gotta point out
that the soundtrack in space jam is on a
whole nother level compared to legacy
every song slaps we got i believe i can
fly space jam
fly like an eagle and new legacy we get
this what up it's parky pig they call me
p
double minor difference here but a new
legacy the basketball is silver while
space jams is more traditional
by half time in both movies michael and
lebron's teams aren't doing well
they're down by a lot and it looks like
all hope is lost however both
versions have different ways of turning
things around in space jam bugs bunny
tells the team if they drink michael's
special drink which is just
water they'll get stronger in new legacy
they get a pep talk from michael jordan
well
not the michael jordan michael b jordan
it's unknown why the michael jordan
declined to be a part of the film
each team has a number of substitute
players my favorite for the goon squad
is kronos but for the tunes we actually
get to see roadrunner don the jersey and
play
which believe it or not he doesn't get
to in the original with the tunes
mounting a comeback the final
game-winning point is put in the hands
of our two protagonists however they go
about this win
in two different ways in space jam
michael learns that he too can
manipulate the physics of the world and
uses this to his advantage by extending
his arm in this super creepy fashion
similarly lebron learns that he can
manipulate the game world by glitching
it this also results in bugs bunny
sacrificing himself but it's okay he's
alive in the next scene
although each film ends happily the
character arcs for michael and lebron
are markedly different
michael learns that maybe baseball isn't
his thing and he returns back to
basketball
lebrons is a bit more emotional as he
learns not to force his son
into playing ball when his dream is
gaming now you might think that bill
murray does not make an appearance in
new legacy but here he is briefly in the
end credits which show the tunes living
their best lives in the real world
in space jam the end credits are simply
filled with shots from the movie
speaking of those credits were you able
to find the only actor to work on both
the original space jam
and new legacy that's bob burgin the
voice of tweety bird funny enough in the
original he also voiced hubie bert and
marvin the martian
they also spelled their wrong names in
those credits no clue why he didn't
voice them a new legacy
life just be like that sometimes but i
want to hear which space jam you think
is superior the original 96 version or
the one with king james
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below and hopefully we can
crown a winner
thanks for watching everyone remember to
like and smash that subscribe button and
check out my other comparison video for
more bad takes you can also follow me on
twitter and instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you